Welcome to Sequencer Features.
The Sequencer UI is straightforward and seems very familiar.
Its design is reminiscent of Adobe After Effects and Premiere, but instead of editing
rendered movie footage, Sequencer edits footage containing animated 3D assets.
The toolbar houses all of the primary settings, menus, render options, and breadcrumb indicators
to help the user navigate between level sequences.
The Outliner on the left adds actors and organizes tracks.
You can drag actors into this area from the Outliner or use the green plus add button.
The timeline manages the playhead, defines track content, and gives a visual display
of what's happening from audio waveforms to setting keyframe indicators.
The selection details pane displays properties and binding information, and the playback
area allows sequence, transport controls, and time range sliders for defining your work area.
Working in combination with Sequencer's Outliner, the event manager and its triggers can be added
to a sequence and tied to specific blueprint endpoints.
This function allows precisely to control when specific events occur within a level sequence.
These triggers could initiate particle systems or tell Unreal when to jump out of Sequencer
and into gameplay.
The Sequencer Curve Editor is a helpful feature for traditional 3D animators.
Specific tracks can be identified, isolated, hidden, or shown within the controls on the left.
Keyframes can be moved, scaled, tweened, and tangents can be weighted or broken as needed
by the artist to control animated motion.
The Sequencer Template is a feature that is intended for ease of use and quick shot creation.
If you know how many shots you'll need and approximately the average length of each shot,
this template can construct a level sequence with shots with as many nested level sequence
shots as you require.
This makes the organization of shots easy, and it can create identical shot parameters
for each nested level sequence.
In this demonstration, we'll take a look at how event management is handled in Sequencer
with a simple example.
By adding an event track into Sequencer, the user can create dedicated triggers that execute
specific functions in what is known as the Director Blueprint.
The Director Blueprint is a special type of blueprint that's tied to your specific level
sequence.
When bound to an actor like a particle system, Sequencer can execute the trigger at a specific
point in time to activate the particle system.
So I have a particle system here.
It's an explosion that I got from the starter content.
If I click on the Admitter and go over to the Details panel, I'll search for Auto Activate
and I want to turn this off.
I don't want the explosion just going off by itself.
Next I'll need to take the explosion and the Admitter and add it into Sequencer.
Actor to Sequencer, Add P Explosion.
Now I'll click on the plus track button and I want to add an event trigger.
This event track will allow me to set keyframes anywhere I want, so I'll just create one here.
Now this keyframe doesn't do anything yet, and the reason for that is it's not bound
to the specific Director Blueprint yet.
To do that, you can do it in one of two ways.
You can either right click over the keyframe itself, go to Properties and click on Unbound,
or you can double click on the keyframe itself.
This will open up the Director Blueprint and you can see our specific P Explosion event.
I'm going to create a toggle active node and make sure that everything is tied together.
I'll compile and I'll go back to our example.
Now we still don't have an explosion yet.
There's one more thing that we have to do.
Right click over the keyframe, go to Properties and say Call in Editor.
Once you do that, anytime that you drag the time marker over the keyframe, the explosion will happen.
There you go.
Anytime that you drag this over there, you'll get another explosion.
You can set as many of these keyframes throughout the event track as you wish.
Next up is the Curve Editor, which is launched within the Sequencers UI and is capable of
refining animation curves, keyframe placements, and tangent settings to achieve the desired
results.
With its unique set of keyframe scaling tools, animators have very precise control over anything
animated within Sequencer.
So I have Manny here and he has a control rig and I've placed some animation on his arm
to do a little wave.
If I want to look at those curves, it's just simply select the IK handle and go into the
Curve Editor.
Now we can see all of the individual keys and the individual curves.
You can view these curves with different viewing modes.
You can use the Transform tool to select curves and scale them from different pivot points.
So right now this is all scaling from the center.
If I put the pivot point down into the corner, I can scale this by that.
There is also the Retime Lattice tool, which is a way to basically retime curves based
off of a two-dimensional lattice.
So by double clicking here, I can add lattice points inside the Curve Editor in order to
scale and modify keyframes.
There's also the Multi-Select tool, which is another mechanism to scale individual curves
or multiple sets of curves, which is also pretty nice.
You can scale horizontally, vertically, etc.
Finally, there's a number of different tangent tools across here.
Selecting these, you can go and put them onto AutoCubic or you can break tangents.
You can weight tangents, make them constant or linear.
There's a number of different functions here within the Curve Editor that are pretty effective.
All right, let's move on to our last feature.
The last feature I want to demonstrate in this module is the Sequencer Template.
Select the function in the Create Level Sequence button and it will allow you to set the number
of shots, their duration, and other specifics like directory placement and numbering settings.
Once it's executed, you can find the parent level sequence and the shots you specified
in the folder of your choice.
So here's the Create Level Sequence button and we'll go up here to Add Level Sequences
with Shots.
I can give it a specific name.
I'll call it Test and it'll be saved in the root path of Game Cinematic Sequences.
I'm going to ask for five shots and each shot will be five seconds in length.
So when I say Create Level Sequence with Shots, it will create the level sequence and you
can see that I have one, two, three, four, five shots and that's located here in Cinematics
Sequences Test.
Alright, this concludes our brief overview of some of Sequencer's features.
Let's move on to our next module that covers some powerful tools.